everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem non-overlapping
intervals and this is actually a problem
from the blind 75 list of questions that
we've been working on and we've actually
been tracking that list of questions on
this spreadsheet you can see that i do
have a video solution on the left side
over here for pretty much every single
problem in this list except for a couple
that we haven't gotten to yet so today
we will be doing the last interval
problem in this list you can see i
solved the other interval related
problems already there's about like 70
people viewing it right now so i hope
that you guys are finding it helpful and
you can see conveniently i made a
youtube playlist for all the blind 75
solutions link to that will be in the
description as well if you do want to
take a look so now let's continue with
the video so this problem is definitely
like most interval problems in that if
you've solved other interval problems
before this one shouldn't be too
difficult but if you're new to interval
problems this one is kind of challenging
so we're given an array of intervals
where each interval has a start value
and an end value and we want to return
the minimum number of intervals that we
have to remove from the list to make
sure that the rest of the intervals are
non-overlapping so first question you
should ask is what exactly is a
overlapping interval well assuming an
interval looks something like this right
it has some start value maybe the start
value is 1 and the end value is two
right maybe we have another interval
that starts at three and goes all the
way to four so definitely these two
intervals are not overlapping but what
if we had uh the interval starting over
here maybe the end point is 3 but the
starting point is maybe 1.5 right
obviously in this case these two
intervals are overlapping right you can
see you know right over here this is the
region that they're overlapping at but
the edge case comes when we have a
interval let's say like this one that's
going maybe starting from two and going
all the way to three are these intervals
overlapping technically you know this
point at position two is overlapping but
technically these intervals are not
considered overlapping right so if they
have the same edge point they do not
count as overlapping this edge case is
very important to understand to solve
this problem okay so let's take a look
at the first example actually so you can
see i've drawn a few of the intervals
and you can see so far these three are
not overlapping right but we're about to
insert the last and fourth interval one
three so it starts at one and goes all
the way until three so now you can see
that they are overlapping with the
introduction of this interval and things
become really simple when you draw a
picture which is why i always recommend
drawing a picture for complicated
problems so now we want to eliminate
intervals we want to eliminate the
minimum number it's obvious that we can
just remove a single interval this one
that we just inserted to make the rest
non-overlapping but of course that's not
the only way we could do it we could
instead remove this interval and remove
this interval so instead we'd remove two
intervals that's clearly not the
solution but there are multiple ways to
do it which is why writing the algorithm
for this problem can be kind of tricky
one definitely possible way to do this
problem is brute force it right go
through every single combination right
for every single interval we can choose
to remove this interval or to keep this
interval and if we have two choices for
every single interval inside the list of
intervals then you know the time
complexity to check every single
possibility is going to be 2 times 2
times 2 basically 2 to the power of n
where n is the size of the input so
that's obviously not very efficient but
can we do better and we definitely can
and it takes a greedy approach to solve
this problem when we're actually given
this list of intervals the ordering of
them could be pretty random right but
you can see when we actually draw the
picture you know why would we want to go
through these intervals in a random
order why would we want to look at this
one then look at this one then this one
yeah right like in just a completely
random order when you look at it this
way it kind of makes sense to want to go
left to right right to see okay here are
they overlapping here are they
overlapping etc etc and the easiest way
to do that is to to iterate through them
in some kind of sorted order you can
probably do it sorted by the starting
point or sorted by the ending point i'm
just going to stick with sorted by the
starting point just because it's a
little bit simpler for me but i know
that it works in both ways for this
problem at least so when we iterate
through these in sorted order first
we're going to compare these two
intervals right we want to compare
adjacent pairs of intervals right and
let's actually ignore this example for
just a second suppose we had just two
intervals right one interval like this
and one interval like this okay they're
in sorted order right and we're
comparing adjacent pairs so we're going
to look at this one and look at this one
how do we know if they are overlapping
well if they're sorted by the starting
point we know that either they both have
the exact same starting point or the
second one has a starting point that's
after the first one's starting point and
that's the case here
but again how do we know if they're
overlapping or not well the easiest way
to check is they're not overlapping if
this one starts after this one ends
right if the second one starts after the
first one ends then they're definitely
not overlapping but on the other hand if
the second one starts before the first
one ends then they're definitely
overlapping right you can see that this
is the point that they're overlapping at
okay so does that cover all of the cases
well there's one more case technically
that's slightly different what if you
know the first one is really long and
the second one starts here right so it
does come after this one but it ends
before the first one ends this is a
slightly different edge case again they
are overlapping we can detect that with
the same condition this one starts
before this one ends so yes they're
overlapping but now suppose we had a
third interval that comes next remember
we are traversing these in sorted order
so first we're gonna compare this one is
first this one is second so then we're
gonna compare these two together next
are we gonna be looking at this one and
this one
in this case yes because remember if
these two are overlapping we don't have
to remove both of them we only have to
remove one of them so the choice is are
we going to remove this one or are we
going to remove this one well which one
do you think we would rather remove
would we want to remove the one that
ends first or the one that ends second
of course we'd want to remove the one
that ends first because then it's
there's less of a chance that it's going
to overlap with the following intervals
that come after and remember we want to
minimize the number of intervals that we
have to delete in this example with
these three intervals it doesn't matter
we could remove this one or remove this
one but let's look at another example
what if the third interval was like this
right it's overlapping with this one
then it becomes pretty obvious we would
want to remove this bottom interval
rather than this top interval and it
depends on which one of these ends first
so that's how we're going to decide
which one to remove and just to look at
a third example so what if they were
inter overlapping like this right of
course we're going to first compare
these two intervals okay yes they're
overlapping and we can detect that
because this one starts before this one
ends so now we have a choice do we
remove this one or do we remove this one
again we're moving the one that ends
first so we're going to remove this one
and you can see
exactly why because now these two do not
overlap but what if instead we decided
to remove this one well we removed it
but it didn't help us because these two
are still overlapping we want to
minimize that so
basically i just explained to you the
exact algorithm that we're going to be
using we're going to sort the entire
array based on the starting value then
we're going to compare adjacent pairs
and then use the conditions that i just
mentioned now what's the time complexity
of this well we're going to sort and
then we're just going to iterate through
the array a single pass right so the
iterating is simple it's just big o of n
we're just going to iterate through the
entire array but the sorting is where
the bottleneck is so that's what the
overall time complexity is going to be
big o log
n log n and just to run the algorithm
that i explained on this input example
because they have the first two starting
values so we're going to have this array
in sorted order based on the start
values we're actually going to take the
first interval and just take its end
value and then keep track of it because
since this is the first interval there's
nothing going to be that comes before it
on the left okay so now we're going to
iterate through the intervals that come
after this one so the first interval is
this one it has the next start value so
we're going to check is the start value
less than
this ones yes they are so they're
overlapping so which one are we going to
delete the one with the larger end value
so we're going to delete this one we can
leave this interval as is and save its
end value so that we can compare it with
the following intervals so this is the
interval that comes next is its start
value less than the end value of the
previous one no it's not so we don't
delete either of these intervals but
since we didn't delete either of these
intervals and since we know this one
started after this one ended we know
that this one is going to have a larger
end value so we're not going to be using
this one to compare anymore we're going
to be using this end value to compare to
the following intervals on the right
side okay so now let's look at this
interval and the next interval that's
coming up is this one so is this one
starting before this one ends nope it
does not so we don't delete either of
these and
uh we just set this to the new end value
that we're going to keep track of but
there's nothing that comes after it so
we're done here we only had to remove
one interval as you can see so the
answer in this case is one which is what
they also had in the output so that's
the entire algorithm now we can actually
code it up it's not too bad
okay so now let's get into everybody's
favorite part writing out the code so
remember the first thing we want to do
is sort the list of intervals so in
python i can just say sort and it'll
actually sort it based on
the entire pair it'll first sort it
based on the start value and then sort
it based on the end value if there's a
tie between the start but you know in
java and stuff you can specify the key
is just the start or you can use just
the end if you want to and then
you can slightly change your algorithm
if you're sorting by the end value but
the result that we're going to keep
track of is just the entire count that
we have to remove so initially it's
going to be set to zero and remember
we're going to initially keep track of
the first end value in our sorted
intervals so we can get that just like
this intervals the first interval and we
want its end value which is at index one
then we're going to iterate through the
remaining list of intervals so we can
iterate through the start and end value
of the remaining intervals like this and
we want to start at index one so we can
specify like that in python and now we
get to our if-else case because we want
to know are they overlapping or not so
they're not overlapping if the start
value of the interval that we're looking
at is greater than or equal to the
previous end value and remember the
equal is very important that's the edge
case we talked about at the beginning if
they're equal they're technically not
overlapping and if they are not
overlapping the only thing we need to do
is update our previous end set it to the
new end value
because we know that the new end value
is going to be greater than the previous
one and the else case is if they are
actually overlapping and if they are
overlapping then we need to remove one
of the intervals so definitely we are
going to increment our result count by
one because we have to remove one of
these now the question is which one are
we going to remove and how are we
actually even going to handle that well
the only thing we actually need to
update is our previous end because
remember we don't actually have to
delete the interval in the array we just
have to count how many we delete but we
have we do have to update the previous
end uh remember which one of these end
values are we actually going to keep
which one of the intervals are we going
to keep we're going to keep the one that
has the minimum end value so we're going
to set previous end equal to the minimum
of end and itself previous end so that
once we've updated this we can use this
new end value uh in the future
iterations of the loop but that's
actually the entire algorithm once we've
done that we just have to return the the
count of how many we deleted and then
run the code and make sure that it works
and as you can see yes it does work and
it is pretty efficient so i really hope
that this was helpful if it was please
like and subscribe it really supports
the channel a lot consider checking out
my patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching